guten Tag wir sind die rtiozwillinge sie
kennen uns aber natürlich kennen Sie uns
wir sind die beiden Zwillinge aus dem
Werbefernsehen ich meine sie sehen wir
Seen uns zu verwechseln ähnlich quasi
total gleich selbst wenn man sich sehr
sehr anstrengen würde könnte man keinen
Unterschied feststellen weil wir
Zwillinge sind ganz gleiche Zwillinge
meine zwillingschwester und ich wir zwei
sind Zwillinge ich habe so schreckliche
Kopfschmerzen die Arme hat total
schreckliche Kopfschmerzen ich aber
nicht obwohl wir Zwillinge sind zwei
total gleiche Zwillinge zwei total
gleiche Zwillinge zwei von einer Sorte
eine zwillingssorte zwei Zwillinge diese
Kopfschmerz mir Platz gleich der Kopf
haben sie nicht irgendwas da vielleicht
von ratioarm natürlich habe ich da was
jetzt bin ich aber gespannt er hat was
da hat er gesagt hast du Gehör hat
gesagt jetzt halt doch mal deine Fresse
bitte das Mittel heißt jetzt halt doch
mal deine
Fresse jetzt halt doch mal deine Fresse
von
rtioarm